the sequel to breath of the wild finally
drops its official name tears of the
Kingdom will be released on May 12th of
2023 so let's take a quick look at what
we saw it put some more insight into
things you might have missed during the
trailer if you enjoy breath of the wild
make sure to subscribe to Gamespot to
keep up with the latest
we open up with multiple scenes with
multiple Stone carvings I won't pretend
to know everything about Zelda lore in
history but what I do know is that
surface level connections can be made
immediately to this creature and its
zonai Origins we then see an incoming
army with the malice of the new
Longhorns and moblins defeating either
hylians or some other tribe we don't
know of yet they obviously look human
but this could be anything from hylians
to chica to some zonai tribe we've never
seen yet we will likely know about this
in the future another thing I'll point
out is that every trailer so far has had
some Ghibli reference thrown in again
this time from nausicaa or nausicaa
Valley of the wind where tapestries of
an aged long past were shown with somber
piano music we have shown this proof
from Castle in the Sky with the floating
land masses with roots growing through
them to how the malice interacted with
Link's arm to Princess Mononoke and more
so it's cool to see that they're keeping
up with this Motif this next scene with
the energy in the center gives the most
information so far it's fairly easy to
find out that this arm here is highly
likely to be the arm that's in the very
first trailer holding down what we still
believe to be Gannon there's ancient
text written down as well the same we
see unfurling from the arm in the very
first trailer unfortunately unlike what
we know about shika and Hylian which we
have online translators for we can't
decipher this text of the new ancient
language as of right now so it's
impossible to know what it says when we
finally do get letter translations we
will finally see what all these letters
mean this owl-like creature is obviously
a powerful deity that could be as major
as a goddess hylia or some other
important figure entirely this part gets
a little tougher to figure out we now
see two figures and two scenes these are
both very likely Zelda or descendant
with the ears and the dress we then see
Zelda cupping her hand with the same
owl-like creature below two tiers we
know this because the same shot pans out
later in the trailer this is obviously
all within deep breath of the wild lore
that just hasn't been revealed yet so
the name of the game here is to take
things at face value and keep them in
your mind until we finally see the truth
unfold now we get to the juicy part we
see link open up a pair pair of massive
doors out into the new Sky area these
doors themselves have intricate designs
of two zonai creatures and with what
looks like a chica eye symbol on the
bottom of the door as well which still
supports the previous idea of the zona's
link to Shiga history this imagery of
the two dragons here also holds
similarities to the hand cupping shown
in the wall designs before we then
finally get a close-up of Link still
donning his amazing highly in tunic
Champions tunic hybrid outfit with the
huge Stone building behind him what's
cool about this shot specifically though
is that this is the first time that we
see these close up in the sky this
finally gives Clarity to the situation
as we previously thought that
long-haired link was purely tied to the
sky only and that there would have to be
time travel between land and sky but
because he is here in this date and with
more shots later in the trailer it's
confirmed that this is one cohesive
world with no State change or loading
between land and Sky you can also see
something located on his hip with what
looks like some sort of ammo belt but
it's unknown exactly what this was for
looking closely though you can see that
this is a zonai designed eye at the top
of the device with containers of light
green energy we associate with the zonai
thinking about it more though if these
containers are placed below the eye like
this these are indeed an idea of a
teardrop this lines up with the fact
that this was simply omitted in previous
trailers and Nintendo clearly stated
that when they reveal the name it will
spoil some aspects of the game so the
choice to reveal it now must link to the
name what doesn't add up though is there
eight container slots not lining up with
the seven tiers surrounding the
important deity shown before so it is
completely unclear on the purpose of
this strange device he then dives off
the edge into Open Sky this is actually
the exact same animation in breath of
the wild for diving into water from high
up but then transitions into the
skydiving animation that they've been
holding back for possibly a decade at
this point remember this skydiving
animation was initially an idea in the
original breath of the wild an imported
idea from a Skyward Sword but of course
is coming in full swing in the sequel
then we see one of the more interesting
Parts link climbs onto a stone slab and
soars upwards with the boulder first
this location is at Corda Lake in the
Faron region in this four pillared zonai
Contraption in the water well my
favorite piece of information about this
trailer is that it sets up the
possibility for rebuilding or fixing the
sky using these pieces from below for
puzzling and exploration think about it
it's clear that from a previous trailer
that the skill with the yellow outline
is a Time reversal mechanic so this must
mean that this piece has fallen
previously from the sky this also May
subtly refer to the title of the entire
game tears of the Kingdom will make a
heck of a lot of sense if the kingdom
was ancient land above and the tears or
tares both work in a situation where
pieces that fell down likely due to a
catastrophic event which was probably
not filled with happy times we also see
a brand new enemy or Wildlife a strange
bat-like creature much larger than a
standard keys but we still have no idea
what it is this next shot supports but
doesn't entirely 100 confirm what I
suspected last year I previously they
said that these islands in the sky have
walls that are severely unfriendly for
climbing similar to Shrine walls you may
not be able to grip onto we see
long-haired link here climbing only the
root on the wall which may support this
Theory we again have to see more footage
to confirm this fact we finally see the
widest shot of the new Hyrule we've seen
so far because of the harsh lighting of
the sunset details are hard to point out
but this shot makes it very clear the
scale of How High these different
Islands actually are another thing is
we've been here before in the previous
trailer we were shown tons of islands
above the Thunder of plateau where we're
dropping down right now but none of
these large islands from before seem to
show up in the right places so this
likely shows that these islands are
things that appear or disappear
depending on some context were still
missing link then transfers from the
skydiving position into the normal
falling position it's unclear at this
point if this is a scripted animation
path to perfectly fall onto this glider
or if this is how the game works in
general with all skydiving detecting how
close you are to the ground before
automatically tilting link to a normal
all this also May prevent comedic
splatting which will be a bummer because
I miss this hilarious interaction from a
Skyward Sword
but we still haven't seen him land on
Solid Ground yet so we'll see in the
future we also see several huge zonai
designs on the ground both at North
Hyrule plain and at the illumini plateau
in this case specifically this sort of
makes sense since the base word is
illuminate which means to light up what
it does specifically though we have yet
to know there's also this spiral
structure here just north of the panther
Bridge stable there's no way to tell
what this is from far away but it does
have a fairly similar spiral design to
the unraveling hand holding down Ganon
from the very first trailer and of
course this Stone glider is the very
last thing we see if you don't believe
me about the Ghibli references yet well
here's another one nausicaa's glider we
don't know if it's fully controllable
but judging by how it's already moving
when link gets there it's hard to say we
finally then see the game name with the
corrupted Master Sword we saw before and
what appears to be two dragons or zonai
creatures in a Circle what's interesting
about this layout is that Nintendo
doesn't Implement stuff just to look
cool these things have a hidden meaning
a snake eating itself or two snakes
eating each other in Greek mythology is
represented as oroboros the cycle of
Life Death and rebirth while it's hard
to decipher what exactly this means
right now I feel like at a minimum this
should be kept in the back of your mind
as we get more information about the
story of The Legend of Zelda tears of
the Kingdom
what are you most excited about with
tears of the Kingdom let us know in the
comments below and to make sure to keep
up with everything Zelda stay tuned with
us here on Gamespot
foreign
[Music]